[Applaudissements]
monsieur le ministre de l'Économie
depuis plusieurs années nous ne cessons
d'appeler votre attention sur l'absence
de maîtrise de la dépense publique
un constat qui est partagé par la Cour
des comptes qui vient de vous adresser
une sévère mise en garde pour ne pas
dire un carton rouge elle dénonce parce
que
quand évidemment
défalqués des exceptionnelles liées à la
crise sanitaire à l'inflation la dépense
publique continue de dériver monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous confirmer que
la France détient bien le niveau le plus
élevé des dépenses publiques en Europe à
hauteur de 58% de notre PIB et Monsieur
le Ministre comment avez-vous pu laisser
ainsi dériver nos comptes publics
pour vous répondre la parole est
communiste de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique Monsieur le Maire
je connais votre attachement monsieur le
sénateur Husson pour rétablissement des
finances publiques donc j'espère que
vous me suivrai dans la méthode que nous
avons proposé qui nous a permis en 2018
de revenir sous les 3% de déficit public
de rétablir les Comptes publics et de
sortir la France la procédure pour
déficit excessif cette méthode c'est
d'abord un objectif
ramener les dépenses publiques de 57 à
50 pour 4% des dépenses qui suppose que
tout le monde fasse un effort et qu'on
s'absienne de déposer des propositions
qui peuvent augmenter la dépense
publique mais qu'on fasse des
propositions pour réduire la dépense
publique
3% de déficit repasser sous ces 3% dès
2027 et réduire la dette publique à
partir de 2026 voilà les chiffres que
nous vous proposons nous proposons aussi
une méthode pour atteindre ces objectifs
une revue des dépenses publiques comme
cela n'a jamais été engagé dans notre
pays consistant à regarder toutes les
dépenses publiques de toutes les
administrations y compris en accord avec
elle celle des collectivités locales
celle des associations celle de l'État
parce que la dépense publique c'est 50%
de dépenses sociales 30% de dépenses de
l'État 20% de dépenses des collectivités
locales et qu'il faut donc que chacun
puisse participer à cet engagement
collectif sur la base un diagnostic qui
doit être partagé nous ferons ensuite un
séminaire sous l'autorité d'après un
ministre pour examiner les dépenses de
l'État et nous assurer que chaque
ministère contribue bien à la réduction
à dépenses publiques je proposerai à
toutes les collectivités locales de
participer également à cet échange et de
s'engager dans cette direction là dans
le respect de la liberté
d'administration des collectivités
locales et nous ferons la même chose
pour les associations et nous aurons des
Assises des finances publiques avant
l'été qui nous permettront d'établir le
calendrier et le montant de réduction de
la dépense s'agissant du calendrier je
le redis notre objectif il est très
simple dès le projet de loiphilange 2024
nous aurons des réductions
significatives de nos dépenses publiques
pour tenir les objectifs que je vous
propose de soutenir monsieur le
rapporteur général monsieur ils sont
monsieur le ministre en septembre
dernier vous aviez annoncé quels
allaient être les dépenses et puis vous
aviez confié le travail à votre majorité
pour trouver des économies vous avez
rendu une copie blanche c'est à dire 0
comment voulez-vous aujourd'hui
entraîner aussi doctement que vous le
présentez à l'instant votre finalement
votre méthode et votre stratégie jamais
la France depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale n'a connu un tel niveau
d'endettement est-ce vrai ou faux c'est
juste une réalité nous allons emprunter
270 milliards d'euros c'est du jamais vu
cette année en 2023 avec des taux
d'intérêts qui remontent donc on se
retrouve en grande difficulté la France
se retrouve en difficulté au moment où
nos partenaires européens ont eux
conduit un certain nombre d'efforts
nous sommes en queue de Plotton sur un
certain nombre de grands indicateurs
d'être public records prélèvement
obligatoire record déficit public qui
nous mettent sur le podium européen
envolée du déficit commercial ça ne peut
pas durer c'est l'affaire des Français
monsieur le ministre je l'ai dit vous
avez pris finalement un carton rouge et
la France par contre ne peut pas être
hors-jeu elle ne peut pas rester hors
jeu alors monsieur le ministre à Caen
des économies merci
[Musique]